عليك فقط أن نلاحظ مرة أخرى
للأشخاص الذين لا يعرفون
أنك انتقدت الرئيس ترامب
لرده على شارلوتسفيل ، لقد
انتقدت الرئيس ترامب
عندما شن ذلك الهجوم العنصري
ضد عضوات الكونجرس الأربع من
النساء الديمقراطيات
أه ثلاث منهن ولدن في
الشخص الأمريكي كان هذا المواطن المتجنس
وعندما قال لهم أن يعودوا من حيث
أتوا ، نادى بذلك
ولكن مرة أخرى أنت جمهوري محافظ
مثل قلبك
وأنت محافظ
إذا لم يكن هناك مكان لك في
الحزب الجمهوري ،
حيث من المفترض أن يذهب أشخاص مثلك ،
لست متأكدًا مما سأفعله بعد ذلك ، لكن دعني
أدلي بتعليق حول
إرسالهم مرة أخرى لأنه ما زال يثير غضبي
أنا
وابني الأصغر جيك ، لقد تبناه من
روسيا
منذ ثماني سنوات واه
أي شخص سيخبرني
أنه ليس مواطنًا ، ليس لديه نفس الحقوق
التي تتمتع بها أنت أو لدي ،
يجب أن أخبرك أنني ضربته
على مؤخرته
وهذا ليس ما تمثله أمتنا
لذا أنا  سأعمل مع
مرشحين أه
يعكسون المبادئ التي أعتقد أه
ينبغي لبلدنا الدفاع عنها ،
سأفعل أولئك الذين يحترمون الآخرين
يكونون هناك مهاجرين
مواطنين جدد ولدوا هنا أم لا
ولأني أعتقد أه
بلدنا أفضل مما
رأيناه و  نعم ، لقد تحدثت عن
عدد من هذه الأشياء
وأه تحمل قدرًا لا بأس به من الجدل
حول تلك الأشياء
أه ولكن أعتقد أن هذه
مسؤولية أي شخص ينتخب القيادة
أو
كقائد فعلت ذلك ولهذا السبب سأنتهي
أه فترتي في الكونغرس من خلال
التحدث علانية في هذه الحالة
أن قيادتنا تدين لنا بشكل أفضل
مما نراه
الآن وحتى أرى أنني سأكون مستقلاً
لأنه ببساطة غير مقبول